let's see i just need to change up the
properties here
there we go that's the display we want
that's what we want right there
i don't know how i did it guys i really
don't i i do not know
how i held off
i mean obviously i know a little bit
because
the title of the trailer you know
hogwarts legacy sebastian sallow's dark
legacy
so they gave away a little bit there and
honestly i knew that much from the
teases already that it was gonna most
likely focus on dark magic
and if you if you guys follow the
channel regularly then some of you know
i just posted the video on dark magic so
a lot of people were like
did you know something was up i
i wish i could claim inside information
on this one i really do
i wish i could claim inside information
alas i cannot i cannot this one was a
pure coincidence one i've been working
on for a while that video and then
whenever they released that teaser with
the spiders i was like ooh i should
probably get this out now
even if some of it becomes outdated
which again i haven't watched yet so i
don't know but even if some of it
becomes outdated that'll be a good kind
of bouncing off point so if you're new
here welcome guys thank you so much for
hanging out
we have been doing this live stream
every tuesday for the past couple of
weeks i think this makes like four in a
row
um
i haven't been looking at the chat much
yet
because i want to just see this
completely fresh
and then we'll dive in so
i have it pulled up here at 4k let me go
ahead and turn off the music here in the
other in the other window
because we want to just i mean we want
to we want to take it all in here take
it all in
so i'm also going to
you know what i think i will let's
switch over to the main
let's switch over to this camera view
and then let's turn that off there we go
now we got to get my webcam in there
got to get the reaction
and then i'll pull it down let's see
maybe like right in here
right in here will be good
all right so
this this is such a weird dynamic right
like most of you have already seen this
and here i am going to be watching it
for the first time so
yeah for those if anybody doesn't follow
me on social media wondering why the
heck did you not stream this live uh i
was working today unfortunately you know
that you know that old thing called work
that some of us have to do every now and
then
uh and i actually do have the
flexibility where i can work from home a
lot but this one it just happened to
fall right
in the middle of like our like my team
we have a weekly meeting once a week and
this this week it was like a big meeting
because we hadn't met in a while so i
was like there's no other way i could
move this there's no way i could get off
to be able to watch the live stream in
real time
so
yeah
here we are a couple of hours later but
you know what the reaction is gonna be
pure and true and you guys are on the
other side of the coin because you've
already seen it so you know what moments
what big moments to wait for so again
all i know uh i did see the announcement
about collector's edition so we're gonna
make sure we talk all about that then
i'll catch back up on the chat here once
i've watched um but yeah it looks like
we've got a one minute fifty second
trailer here hogwarts legacy sebastian
sallows dark legacy and before i dive in
yeah i wanna make sure i turn off all
the alerts
okay yeah all alerts are disabled so
guys if you sub or if you donate or
anything right now thank you so much
appreciate it it will not pop up on
screen as soon as we're done with this
though then we'll shift into the other
view and all the alerts will pop up and
everything so
all right guys let's dive in
this is the official retro right into a
reaction to the brand new hogwarts
legacy dark trailer
all right let's do this man i've waited
long enough let's dive in
the more we know about salazar slytherin
and the dark arts the best preparations
will be the 4k quality if either of you
uses dark magic i will notify the
headmaster immediately
hmm
unforgivable curses are so named
for a reason uh oh
save your life shouldn't be unforgivable
the dark hearts seem harmless until it's
too late
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever
what do we do now
it's up to us i can teach you crucio
or i can cast it on you
what
[Applause]
well there we go
there we go
another unforgivable
confirmed
dude that looked like the door looked
like chamber of secrets
obviously not the chamber but
oh my gosh man you have the two of you
done
i guess she went along with it
[Music]
oh
dark arts pack pre-order digital deluxe
edition
okay it looks like we
pre-order on august 25th okay yes so i
did see the announcement about that
i did see that announcement
oh my goodness dude that was that really
one minute and 50 seconds that flew by
that was just
that flew by too quick
we were spoiled man after the big 14
minute reveal okay
all right so
crucio confirmed seemingly
and just a very dark
very dark trailer right there
uh and i still don't think we know
who that guy is with the beard i think
most people are probably thinking
a lot of people were thinking maybe
that's the care of magical
creatures professor or maybe it's
sebastian's father all right we gotta we
gotta watch it again let i go i gotta
watch it again i gotta watch it one more
time
now that i know what i'm looking for
here more we know about salazar
and the dark arts all right
i'm not even gonna try to break it down
yet let's just watch it through one more
time
then i'll catch up on chat
and then we're gonna go through
obviously looking at all this in great
detail so the best prepared all right
hold on
the more we know about what does he say
salazar the more we know about salazar
slytherin and the dark arts the best
prepared we'll be
if either of you uses dark magic i will
notify the headmaster immediately
unforgivable curses are so named
for a reason
a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable the dark
hearts seem harmless until it's too late
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever what do we do now it's up
to us i can teach you crucio
or i can cast does he have to do crucio
to get past that door
i'm ready
oh and she's a hufflepuff too it just
doesn't feel right
this definitely looks like the dungeon
where the uh what have the two of you
done that we saw on the other trailer
wow okay man so apparently sebastian
whatever that family curse is
yikes
maybe he has to get
i don't know they have to go okay let's
i'm gonna pause it on this now dark arts
pack thestral mount so is the leak
confirmed i don't remember the onyx
hippogriff mount i feel like that one's
different but all this other stuff i
feel like we uh
is what was leaked 72 hours early access
dark arts garrison hat maybe that one
was in there too and i just forgot about
it but
wow okay all right let me go ahead and
actually you know what i'm gonna go i'm
gonna leave it right here
and now i'm gonna finally look at chat
i'm gonna finally look at chat now let's
switch over to the commentary view there
we go so now all the alerts will be
turned back on the leak was true hey
expect to go what's up
wizardphd here as well welcome guys hey
thanks for stopping by and hanging out
all right let me try and catch up
obviously not gonna be able to go all
the way back through
um but i see jason here youtube member
jason dylan is here as well thank you
guys so much for being here and hanging
out jay rossi in the house we got arkham
knight
britney smith guess who
we got fandom draws welcome
nico hey another youtube member nico
thank you so much for being here matthew
i'm so hyped it looks so good okay
let me just say right off the bat what
i'm disappointed with
where's the gameplay man where's the
gameplay
come on
give us some gameplay i
i love the vibe the vibe of this is
insane
and i also saw where chandler said
that again i was trying like i was
trying to avoid something obviously i
avoided the trailer all day but then i
still got alerts whenever chandler made
a post so
i saw when he posted this one right here
hold on i'm gonna pull it over so you
guys can see
exactly the one i'm talking about here
uh chandler actually released a couple
of different things here
let's see
where is it
oh it might have been a reply to
somebody i'm having trouble finding it
right now
uh what do you all think yeah i saw that
one oh yeah this right here this is the
one
so this is kind of crazy guys
this right here
this is kind of crazy right
look at this what if i told you that
pretty much everything you see here is
part of an optional quest line
our sebastian sallow's dark legacy
trailer focuses on sebs
is that another like nickname so that we
have like uh natty or natsai
focuses on seb's companion quests which
you can choose to undertake
and then it also so we got choice there
then it also has that other layer of
choice when they come to the door
and he says something like i can i can
teach it to you or i can cast it on you
so i think
him casting it on you would be a way for
you to stay true to the good stay true
to the good side
but still be able to progress that quest
i saw chandler answering some questions
for people about that too so
we'll get into some of that as well but
oh man you guys uh let's see you're
talking about collector's edition
pricing and that sort of thing
we got strawberry here
we got feathers mcgraw hey feathers
mcgraw welcome back ezra
let's see i already said ultra blue ao
welcome mr vette welcome guys so what do
you guys think what do you guys think
about it obviously i'm sad we didn't get
to see game play
rain and thunder high five holds out
hand love the channel amazing job eh
thank you so much dude
thank you so much
potterhead can you guys see anything i
only see a dark screen oh man i hope it
worked
arkham knight already saw but it's still
cool
so yeah i i really like i haven't looked
at a lot of the reaction online at all
so oh that's another thing i want to
check let me check now and see what
because i put up a poll and i said i'm
not going to look at the results here
all right thoughts on the new hogwarts
legacy trailer
fun to reflect back on later
and give my thoughts before looking at
the poll results okay yeah so i gave you
guys my thoughts so now let's take a
look at this
most of you say acceptable most of you
see are acceptable you know what i would
agree with this right here i would agree
with this
hey bear thank you for subbing to the
channel welcome
i would agree with acceptable um it did
not exit expectations there were parts
of it that were outstanding i'll say
alex gaskin a thank you for subbing to
the channel welcome
um and obviously we couldn't fit
dreadful and troll so i think it was i
think it was good
see we were spoiled is the problem we we
got really spoiled seeing so much when
that that four big 14 minute plus reveal
and then we had the developer thing
after
going in i wasn't of course we couldn't
expect that you know this was a trailer
part of something much larger let me see
what you guys are saying over on youtube
as well because i put up a poll there
too
let's see how the poll is looking there
uh yeah i think you have like one more
option on youtube
hey the potter collector even doing a
live reaction i love it man
i love to see some of the bigger content
creators starting to cover this game
more and more because it is
it's going to be a big deal guys
if you didn't know that already it's
gonna be a big deal all right let me go
to posts here
this post right here all right so we've
gotten about three
3 500 votes so far
here we go
and same thing here the majority of
people so only two percent dreadful five
percent troll 55 acceptable 21 exceeded
expectations and 18 outstanding yeah i
think you guys i think the votes nailed
it i really do
uh obviously there's gonna be a even
though it was so short there's gonna be
a lot of content here
because there was a lot of lines in this
one that as they were saying them
i was like wait a second does that mean
what i think it means
and then also all of the like the things
on the wall and the snakes moving we're
gonna dive in here we're gonna dive in i
don't know how
how in depth we'll be able to go the
book with the skull has the deathly
hallows reign and says
very interesting jay rossi i think he's
talking about sebastian here for now
he's just a guy that talks about
shrivelfig's being oh the uh the guy
with the beard yeah shrivelfix being
unable to reverse a curse
and also now apparently he's uh reign of
thunder says maybe he's the keeper of
the ground oh uh
what do they call hagrid
uh the gamekeeper yeah or groundskeeper
some people refer to him as
perhaps both his father and someone who
works at hogwarts that's possible too
all right we got it we definitely gotta
go back and look at this skull book
though skull book that has
the deathly hallows on it that would be
like the oh my goodness ladies and
gentlemen we got fred weasley here fred
welcome to the stream
can't get over the crucio on the ground
yeah
i mean and that if they're confirming
crucio now
imperio take it to the bank right you're
not going to have two of the three and
then leave
leave out imperial imperio i think is
the one that actually has the most
use in a in a video game setting
honestly i mean avada cadaver of course
like
instant death on things right but
uh imperial that one you could really
make for some interesting gameplay
scenarios new trailer was kind of
underwhelming i could feel that i could
feel that a little bit but i i enjoyed
it
but i can i get why some people might
say that wondering how dark you could
actually become in the game there you go
very dark right
right
collector's edition yeah we got to talk
about that too the collector's edition
being announced um is going to be
revealed tomorrow which
i may try and hop online and do like an
early morning live stream because
i don't i know some people are saying
that pre-orders
which expect to go if you're still here
obviously i gotta get caught up on all
the news or anybody here honestly do you
guys know
why are some people saying the 25th for
pre-ordering
the collector's edition
has that been officially confirmed by
anybody
so far all i've seen is
oh wait the trip hold on the trailer
said
the trailer said pre-order okay so
that's the deluxe edition though
and i did also see that chandler
confirmed this is the new cover
for the deluxe edition
so i don't think this is going to be the
cover
for the um
the final one
oh my goodness the super chat coming in
from farrett fire red is that how you
say it
dude thank you so much
for the super chat just wanted to say
keep up the good work and what did you
think of the deluxe edition yeah good
timing right there i love the cover
dude this is sick look at the difference
in the uh in the robe here
than in the cover that we've all got so
familiar with look at the difference in
the robe and then you've got the
inferior here
i want to see if chandler posted did
chandler post like the full
resolution shot of it
because i really want to see that
let's see chandler
there he is
oh yes right here he says i love this
animated version of our new key art
been waiting quite some time to show
this off the dark arts seem harmless
unless it's too late and then i think he
might have said in a reply yeah he said
this is the key art for our oh yeah so
i'm i'm getting ahead of myself here
oh because there's so many things here
all right um this person uh asked him
will this be the definitive cover for
the game and if i don't want to be a
dark wizard he said this is the key art
for our deluxe edition the regular key
art you're used to is still used for the
standard edition so i guess officially
that is confirmed as the uh cover
i don't think we ever got like
confirmation for that exactly
and then i love this part your legacy is
your own even if you undertake seb's
optional quest you don't have to choose
to engage with the dark arts ladies and
gentlemen more super chats coming
through
[Applause]
oh fire t yeah see i was making it too
difficult
nico hey thanks for the super chat niko
a reminder to do a live stream poll for
people's houses
okay yeah we could we could do that here
let's see how many people in the chat
here
let's do a house poll see how the the
chat breaks down oh yeah and i said i
have a surprise for you guys too so we
got to do the surprise here as well all
right create a poll
what is your
hogwarts
house
yes or no
gryffindor ravenclaw
hufflepuff
make sure i spell them right i almost
always make a typo when i do these polls
and slytherin
ask your community
boom
there we go
ask and ye shall receive nico ask and he
shall receive
okay so yeah this chandler though i i
think that's exactly what we saw the
choice right there when sebastian says
um
basically
i can cast it on you or i can teach it
to you if you want to be the dark arts
teach it to you obviously if you want to
complete that quest but you do not want
to engage with the dark arts then pretty
clear you're going to say
yikes i guess you just stand there and
have it cast on you
as brutal as that sounds
yeah the contrast is great let's let's
blow this up here so you've got the
dementors which i guess dementors
again confirmed we hadn't seen any sign
of dementors since that first trailer so
people were kind of wondering wait are
they in are they out
again confirmation here i think this is
the fact if they're gonna be on the the
cover of the deluxe edition dementors in
the game i think we take it to the bank
and then
looks like two thestrals i don't want to
get it wrong and one of my uh
one of my videos i got it wrong when it
was a dragon i thought it was a thestral
but those both of those look like
thestrals then you've got the green
powering up on the wand right there and
then you have the inferior right there
oh that is sick i love that but yeah i
can't wait to see what they have in
store for the
collector's edition tomorrow
which i guess the if now that we know
that the leaks are pretty much confirmed
in terms of that
then i think we already know what what
to expect here
i think we know what to expect
by the way oh yeah i said i had a
surprise for you guys oh yeah let's do
let's do the surprise here
let's go
let's go full cam for a second
let's go full cam
anybody noticed
anybody notice something right here
anybody anybody uh caught sight of that
let me zoom in here a little bit and fix
my
my camera
anybody caught sight of uh what might be
going on here
i don't think i've showed this to
anybody yet
unless expect a ghost here expecto go
got an early look
oh yeah i did show a little tease that's
right
hey tazbard
thank you so much for the super chat
there honestly i feel there was probably
an earlier choice where you can try to
convince sebastian not to do this
interesting that may open a way to heal
his curse problem without resorting to
meddling with the dark arts i like that
i like that that's an interesting theory
and thank you so much for the support of
the channel in the super chat all right
let's do it let's do a full reveal here
of the of the shirt
check it out man what do you think order
of merlin
order of merlin
this was designed by
an artist
that i reached out to on twitter
and
he absolutely
knocked it out of the park
with this design
and
you guys can actually let me pull this
up here
um
i have them available in my in my little
uh shop
right now
uh like like like now you can go on you
can go in there and get them
so it is a it's a it's 26.99 because
it's it's a little bit nicer of material
this is a really soft one they have like
a standard one which i could have done
for probably you know five six bucks
cheaper
but this one is going to be a much nicer
material and
i didn't want to promote this i didn't
want to push this out until
i
actually could try it out for myself so
i have them in now i know the quality um
they do smell funny they do when you
first open the package i was like man
this smells really strange
but it's already kind of wearing off
smells wearing off but as far as like
the feel goes i love the feel and oh i
have some of these too i did order
i got some of these as well
make sure you guys can see that there
these little stickers
which these are pretty big
i mean just to give you a
have like a waterloo here so you guys
can get an idea on the size i mean
they're basically
almost as tall as a regular can there
so expect a goal
do not purchase these i know i know you
probably want to but expect a go
uh has has a free one heading his way
so i am the as the sort of father of the
merlin theory
oh and i need to switch screens don't i
so you guys can see this
there you go
and i posted the link in the chat if any
of you get if any of you guys are
interested in checking it out we got the
shirt obviously and then i just showed
off the sticker as well and then we also
have the mug available you can do it as
like a phone case
and you can do it as a poster if you
want it on a poster
expect to go you got a free shirt coming
your way and you got a free uh sticker
coming your way
so hope you guys uh oh he's expecting
goes like i'm already on the store now
hey thank you so much man but yeah you
got you got a shirt coming sue's got a
shirt coming and you got a sticker
coming so
whatever else you want to buy to support
the channel there you go
so i've been
like i said i've had these designs i've
been sitting on them for so long wanting
to tell you guys about them
and i just like i'm like i want to hold
off till i have them in hand i want to
be able to vouch and say that hey it's
good quality stuff
so there you go they're officially out
and available
uh
looking good wendy do you get that ray
says yeah i just got it today like it
was perfect timing
they just came in the mail today and i
was like oh this is perfect i can talk
about them on the live stream tonight
about to make voldemort look like a
saint reese says
jason i'll be the descendant of merlin
and morgana keeping that your head canon
what if we meet voldemort's grandfather
ravenclaw oh yeah let's see the results
let's take a look at the poll results
here
let's see
right now ray oh ravenclaw is actually
dominating dude where are my gryffindors
at
where are the fellow gryffindors
we got ravenclaw at the top with 33
slytherin second at 26
hufflepuff 21 gryffindor at only 20
come on where are my bold and true
gryffindors you guys
where the bold and true
you're a wizard harry
dude i love having that as my alert i
don't know if i will ever change that as
the uh
you're a wizard harry
devin thank you so much for subscribing
appreciate it
there we go dylan throwing out the the
gryffindor icons
dylan didn't you say you're kind of like
a
you're you're a cross between uh
slytherin and gryffindor that you can
never figure out exactly
which one you are
slytherin pride hey ralph slytherin i
with a name like that i'm not surprised
oh my
there we go we got a couple gryffindors
trickling in now a couple gryffindor's
trickling in
all right so you guys fill me in man
what other news have i missed i know
that chandler has
confirmed we're getting collector's
edition details tomorrow morning
a lot of people i think are taking this
right here
everybody's saying pre-order august 25th
but that says deluxe edition ever since
the whole playstation 5 debacle you guys
i don't trust
i don't trust the retailers like this
may be what hogwarts legacy is saying
but i'm telling you guys if the details
are coming out tomorrow honestly like we
better be scouring the internet tonight
things things could drop tonight
oh did i miss some super chats let's go
let me scroll back up here
i might need to
go into my other window
oh i don't want to end the poll yet
oh no why did the super chats oh wait
there we go there we go
vol usa dark gryffindor going to be a
blast
oh that's the one that just came in darn
it vault thank you so much for
supporting the stream valusa or val usa
i don't know
thank you so much for supporting the
stream with the super chat
but yeah i got to figure out how to go
back
i got to figure out how to go back
oh there we go hi send a super chat i
got it now hi
hi one two three and expecto go coming
in with the 20 super chat expect to go
thank you so much
okay so hi says a retro say lumos on
your on your phone and when you have a
chance and look at the back of it also i
think online will be realized way after
um i think online will be released way
after the release of hogwarts like in
red dead two uh i'm not sure what you
mean by online are you thinking like
multiplayer i i used to think that exact
thing but they pretty much have shot
down multiplayer and then uh looks like
jon jon so sorry i missed that john came
in with a super chat as well
could arrive quidditch tryouts uh could
arrive quidditch oh could arrive after
quidditch tryout so no quidditch
oh like you're thinking we our character
maybe arrives late
that's possible
i feel like we don't arrive
because we it's pretty clear we don't
arrive at the school on the hogwarts
express
but then
yeah i don't know i feel like we'll be
there for most of the school year but
that is an interesting idea like that
would be a way for them not to include
it's like a you just you arrived late
sorry
oh goodness all right let's i've heard
this the thing about the iphone but i've
never been able to get to work
lumos
yeah says who would you like to call
lumos
there we go dude it does work
nice
okay i've turned torch on
it says
oh that's funny yeah i'd heard about
that before and i could never get to
work before so there we go got it to
work
got it to work right there
all right let's see what uh expect to go
and another super chat from high right
there
thank you so much i meant to say you
siri oh yeah you didn't have to super
chat again for that
thank you though very much
yeah it was um
i figured it out probably by the time
you sent that
apologies okay expecto go says
officially a member of the order of
merlin
let's go hey thank you so much expecto
go thank you for your support man i know
i
true story james true story i
i clicked onto your stream because i was
i was at work and i had a little bit of
time for before my meeting
and i clicked onto your
stream and
like right when i click on
jeff keeley switches the hogwarts legacy
appears in the background and i was just
like
oh man you talk about like the willpower
to be able to click the x off of
watching your reaction right then and
there
oh man it took a lot but i did i clicked
away i didn't look but i so wanted to
watch it i can't wait to go back and uh
after the stream tonight check out
everyone's reactions so
expect a ghost question though guys
merlin do we think he is a main story
quest
salazar
side story quest morgana question
question question
dude at this point i'm like
because chandler confirmed what we just
saw like that is a completely
optional request
request
quest that's completely optional quest
let's go ahead and get some music going
again i thought i was like something's
missing guys
something's missing let's bring our
tavern music back
[Music]
um
oh man at this point
i mean they explicitly mentioned salazar
slytherin as
being
important for that quest so yeah i think
i feel like we could confirm his side
quest merlin i still don't know if i
think merlin's going to be like part of
the main story or if merlin is a side
component to
i mean who knows at this point
[Music]
and now we wait on uh morgana now we
wait
oh dude
[Music]
does pre-orders means they're going to
reveal the pc system requirements john
asks john that's another good question
uh i feel like
it sounds like tomorrow they're going to
give collectors collectors edition info
[Music]
and
that will be the point oh dude you know
what i just realized they don't show a
pc version up here do they
[Music]
digital
no this doesn't say digital edition this
just says delivers edition
hey yannick thank you so much for
subbing to the channel
you're a wizard harry oh like can i vote
in my own poll
oh no i just broke with the chat
when i tried to vote in my own poll
completely broke the chat for a minute
there corey 8500 gaming subbing to the
channel as well corey thank you so much
and then there was one more that came
through just before that i believe
[Music]
welcome to you as well apologies
do you think azkaban will be in the game
i think so
it was that was clearly a shot of it in
that first the very first trailer
it's right there wait where do you i
don't see a pc version anywhere up here
i mean it says pc down here
but it doesn't say pc version up here we
got switch we got two the two different
xbox versions and then the two different
ps4 versions
[Music]
so i guess this one only includes i did
want to jump back i guess this one only
includes um
yeah it only includes digital things so
there should be no reason that this is
not
also made available for pc you're just
not gonna get the cool the cool box
right and the cover and everything
[Music]
deluxe better or collector collector
will be the most expensive one for sure
that's gonna be the one with
physical components like the uh the
ancient magic wand with the book
if the leak was right on that
oh let's see we had a deathly house
oh and hi hi was asking how do you join
so
if you go to
just go to my channel here
so right here there's there's a join
button
[Music]
and i think it's like 4.99 yeah it's
4.99 to join
and whenever you join you'll get like
these loyalty badges and you'll get the
custom emoji that you can use in the
live chat
which if you guys have ideas for this
like youtube actually gives you a lot of
flexibility on
we could add multiple tiers like you can
go as like i could have a 99 cent tier
you can have like a ten dollar tier so
if you have ideas for other things you'd
like to see in this let me know we do
have um
more emoji slots as well that we've
unlocked
but i just don't know what to make them
yet
because these four i mean it made
perfect sense right to have the four
the four uh house icons but then the
next ones i don't know so i'm open to
hearing your ideas see what you guys
think but yeah that join button should
also appear
on any video as well oh my goodness
another sub to the channel that i have
no idea how to pronounce
thank you so much for subscribing
you're a wizard harry and oh dude we got
a sebastian subscribing as well
sebastian thank you so much
all right i'm gonna leave the poll open
for about two more minutes or so
clash thank you so much for subscribing
to the channel as well
right isn't that crazy ryan
everything they they showed us was
optional jyn coming in with a
subscription as well
man you guys are
rocking it with the subs tonight thank
you so much
don't care about a physical wand already
got one from disney world
well i made a video a while back long
before we knew that a collector's
edition was going to be a real thing
about what i would like to see and i
actually said no wand because
exactly what you're just talking about
there the wand i mean it's been
they're ones everywhere
yo dylan coming in with the super chat
as well
dylan thank you so much for the super
chat
dylan always showing big time support of
the stream man very much appreciated
[Music]
retro not sure if you mentioned it
but what edition do you plan on getting
and let's get
oh hold on it's cutting off part of the
chat
let's get more icon options yes dude we
definitely need some new icon options oh
i'm for sure going for the collectors
i mean as somebody who covers the game i
just i feel like i we got to do the
unboxing you know
break it down review everything
[Music]
but i will i will give you guys like
once we see everything that's in it
and right now who knows what this
ancient magic wand with book is gonna
look like is it is it all a statue is it
a wand that you know you can actually
hold and carry around
is it a wand that's like sort of
put on a pedestal with this book like
for display the quality of it i want to
see all those types of things and i will
i will try and give you guys
my complete honest opinion on if i was
like if i wasn't covering the game as
closely would i still buy it because i'm
actually very very picky with my
collector's editions i'm trying to think
i've only bought
oh man
i could think of three off the top of my
head
i bought the um the special edition of
the metroid prime trilogy
which really it was just a steel book
or a steel case with all three games
actually i still have it it's right
right there
the wii version
right there is where i have that one
sitting
i also got the one for
infamous is probably my favorite
collector's edition of all time infamous
two i still use the backpack that came
with that
i still use that backpack to this day
man
all right i'm gonna go ahead and turn
off the poll only because it's blocking
like half the chat so i can i can't see
everything
that i need to see my apologies but
ravenclaw and slytherin actually ended
up tying and gryffindor did end up
passing hufflepuff so it was the final
results if i go ahead and hit in poll
here i think it'll show you guys in the
chat but
ravenclaw and slytherin's at the top
[Music]
but yeah dylan that's definitely the
addition i'm gonna be going with the
collectors but we'll see i mean we don't
even know pricing either right we have
no idea on pricing
and we have no idea
when the collector's edition will go on
sale they have said tomorrow morning
guys
9 00 a.m
eastern time
hold on let me make sure i get that
right
i'm pretty sure that's it but i want to
i want to just triple check
before i tell you guys that information
all right where's that
oh my goodness
welcome another member welcome ryan
thank you so much
welcome to gryffindor
ryan's like hold on a second i'm not a
gryffindor
i'm not a gryffindor
demonic one a demonic one what's up
remember you from the youtube comments
thanks for stopping by and i think i've
seen you in uh expect a ghost chat
before too
collector's edition dude why can i not
i keep just like stumbling over when i
try to say the word collectors
collector i'm just getting so hype
collector's edition
will be 299 demonic one says
don't know where information is coming
from some websites are reporting
collector's edition is 300 razer says
225
interesting
yeah
i ca i mean gosh 300 seems a little
steep but we just we have no idea
hey and hi becomes a member as well
thank you so much guys welcome welcome
you've been here for a while hi you you
know how we do things around here
but yeah now you can use those uh slick
emojis there in the chat
[Music]
so this one though for sure pre-order
august 25th
that is like the official pre-order
though
the retailers this is what i was saying
earlier i got i got sidetracked there's
so much to talk about
the whole playstation 5 fiasco guys it
all started because sony gave a time
and then the retailers everybody ended
up blaming sony for it i mean part of it
was their fault but the retailers just
started going crazy it was like walmart
it pops up at this time then target then
best buy then now it's on amazon then
some people waited some people didn't
wait
and it was just a nightmare and
everybody was like scrambling trying to
get them so
honestly like if you know for sure you
100 want one of these collectors
editions i would put chandler
finch strife if you have twitter
put alerts on
for him
[Music]
because he would definitely be the one
to give the official information
i'm actually going to pull up his post
right now so we can all read
exactly
what it says here
so this is the post from him
we'll be showing you the hogwarts legacy
collector's edition tomorrow
now we also
from the official hogwarts legacy
account
got this right here
information regarding the collector's
edition for hogwarts legacy will be
revealed tomorrow 8-24 at 6 a.m pacific
time dude
i i feel like that's pre-order time guys
i'm not gonna lie
i really feel like that is pre-order
time so for my west coast folks you're
gonna have to get up a little bit early
this is nine a.m eastern time i will
probably
honestly start looking as soon as i wake
up in the morning i will start checking
i may even try to hop on and do a live
stream before work
just to kind of keep everybody informed
um
i have this is like 39 of you have liked
this comment is this when pre-orders go
live so i tried to ask them you guys i
tried
and we have not gotten like an official
answer
oh this is interesting so it looks like
somebody
this must be where everybody's trying to
get the the price guessing right here
is there a price for the deluxe edition
and can they sell out if they are
digital downloads
well that one you shouldn't have to
worry about digital deluxe you should be
fine
logan coming in with the super chat
logan thank you so much for supporting
the stream supporting the channel
being a super fan ever since i was a kid
and i'm 30 now i just feel like i owe it
to myself to buy the collector's edition
oh dude i know right it's like
it's exciting and then there's also part
of you at the same time that's just like
a wizard they got me you know they got
me
of course i also bought the collector's
edition of you're a wizard you guys
remember that tales of beetle the bard
collectors edition
and thank you guys for those recent subs
that just uh came through there looks
like we had three come in right there
back to back to back wizard oh we got
four coming in
[Music]
thank you guys so much
but yeah it was a wizard harry another
one
zanore as well thank you guys for
subbing to the channel
got work at nine hey you work from home
nice
i mean i'll be honest with you guys like
why
why else would it be that early in the
morning
i just feel like it's gonna be like we
are here's the collector's edition it's
live go pre-order now
and those 100
will be
in limited quantities
100 will be in limited quantities
um also know in your head know which
version you're gonna want
another tip for you guys if you've been
on the fence
if you've been on the fence about trying
to decide which version you want make
sure you have that
ready to go tomorrow
um
this one is not like in the early days
of ps5 you could like buy the ps4
version of course you could play the ps4
version but if you have a ps5 you
definitely want to make sure you go for
the ps5 version
same thing for the xbox series x
so you could play the older one on there
but it will not
uh i do not believe they've announced
any kind of like free upgrade or
anything like that so
but yeah that old collector's edition of
tales of beetle the bard
i felt more comfortable buying that one
because i'm like it was going to charity
a very large portion of the
sales of that book were going to charity
so it's like this massive i have it
upstairs in my bedroom it's this massive
book and then you open it up and the
actual tales of peter labard is a much
smaller book let me see if i can find
that
i know you guys
you guys will remember this
beetle the bard
collectors edition
[Music]
oh yeah here's a good picture of it
right here
honestly this this doesn't do the sizing
justice though or a wizard i mean this
book is it's huge actually in hand
absolutely huge
edward thank you for subbing to the
channel as well
yo we got rolling library in the house
rolling library what is up thank you so
much for stopping by
enjoying your videos a lot keep up the
good work thank you so much and you keep
up the good work as well rolling library
guys does a great job of uh
if you're not following them on twitter
they tweet out a lot of harry potter
related
news
and actually i believe you were the one
who broke the story on the hogwarts
legacy art book long before we had any
kind of uh official announcement on that
so
thank you so much for stopping by and
your support of the channel very much
appreciated
logan hope you can find a ps5 in time
dude they are coming more and more
available
there was a uh my cousin's actually
looking for one right now so i've been
knowing i've been paying attention to
tweets and stuff like that
a playstation direct has actually been a
really good source lately
there is also a i think his name is jake
randall
really awesome youtuber who has like
built his whole channel on
uh helping people get ps5s so he like
monitors the walmart restock target
restock when they restock when you need
to sign on all that kind of stuff
so uh i'm pretty sure it's jake randall
look him up and also wario64
on twitter
if you if you guys are still trying to
get one of the consoles guys wario64 on
twitter jake randall on twitter and or
youtube
and also playstation direct
and then just some some really quick
high level pro tips
whenever you're getting ready to
pre-order
or try and get in the line or whatever
get in the queue make sure you're signed
in so it's like if you're buying on
target you want to make sure you are
signed into your account that you have a
payment method saved because what
happens to a lot of people is they
they're able to add it to the cart and
then they get to check out and they're
not signed in or they don't have a
payment method saved in there and ready
to go and so then before they can get it
all added kicks them to the back of the
queue or they just
somebody else orders it before they can
so those are some just uh just some
quick tips
in stock at playstation direct right now
feathers mcgraw says yo
there you go
let's see i'm gonna look this up
yeah cause i checked earlier today
when i saw some tweets go out and
they were they were up for a while i
noticed
[Music]
yeah here you guys go right now
direct.playstation.com
buy now
yeah so you gotta sign in to buy so oh
it looks like they have both they have
the horizon bundle and they just have
the console
by the way
how about that new ps5 controller that
announcement kind of came out of nowhere
came out of nowhere i was not expecting
that
spaceman what's up got yours thanks to
jake yeah jake's awesome dude his
twitter account and his uh
is youtube he's got some great videos on
helping people out with that
[Music]
ryan can't wait for physical merch ryan
i've heard
i've heard some things that physical
merch for hogwarts legacy is coming
i have heard that it is indeed coming
but that is not like
that's not anything official
[Music]
yeah and i saw some more questions about
collectors edition guys all all we know
about collectors edition right now is
that they're announcing more tomorrow
that's it
that is all we know right now
um
this
this pre-order on august 25th
as far as i'm concerned this literally
just applies to the deluxe edition
for now now maybe they come out tomorrow
morning and say august 25th at 11 a.m
pacific time is the collector's edition
i don't know
but one thing that i have said for a
while now is
whenever they announce this collector's
edition man they better make sure people
have time to pre-order like i would
here's what i would much prefer happen i
would prefer they come out tomorrow and
say hey here's everything in the
collection edition
it's going live this friday
at
this time and on the websites of these
retailers
that way everybody can prepare
you you don't have to like because
tomorrow if it if it goes live tomorrow
tomorrow morning there's going to be a
mad dash
and i wonder what cover the collector's
edition will get
if this is gonna be the cover of the
deluxe edition
so intriguing right
ghost of tsushima and cyberpunk
collectors edition yeah i love the
infamous 2
collectors edition
predictions for switch release date oh
man
that's a tough one i'm just i'm feeling
like a month out right now
so february
although now you guys now that the 72
hour early access is confirmed which i'm
actually not a huge fan of that i don't
i don't like the idea of paying for
early access but
it is what it is you know it is what it
is
uh so now the game is actually going to
be launching
yo aspect
a new member here on youtube aspect
thank you so much
for becoming a member here on youtube
thank you for the support of the channel
now you can use those slick new emoji i
saw somebody suggest a merlin emoji
that's a great idea
that is a great idea
[Music]
all right sorry i'm getting behind on uh
i gotta scroll back down to catch up
with the
the comments here
[Music]
george weasley oh george that's a more
poet you've changed up your name there
i see that comment
yeah it's just it's moving pretty fast
let me see if you asked another question
i see a heart there from you have a
question don't want to spam because i've
asked it three times already
what oh my goodness i'm sorry
when do you think we'll get something
more other than dark arts i'm jonesing
for something new that actually excites
me ah because you're not a big dark arts
fan okay
[Music]
well
[Music]
here's the thing george
i am like you
i'm like you in that
the dark arts i think it's great that
they're having it all in the game
tyler welcome thank you for subscribing
and i will definitely do it in a second
play through but for me
it's not how i will play the game in my
like first preferred playthrough however
as someone who's been making content on
this game for like two plus years now
the dark arts are like
big time
in terms of like the interest level of
fans when i first started making videos
on this like
the comments i would get all the time
are are we gonna be able to use the
unforgivables are we gonna be able to
use the unforgivables
any time i do a poll about unforgivables
anytime i do a video about how
open-ended the game is gonna be
anytime i do stuff about any of that
it's always the dark art stuff so this
is a case of avalanche
100
knowing their audience i guarantee you
chandler wood
and some of the other marketing folks
have read your host comments on on
youtube videos
they have seen the types of videos that
get more i mean look at this let me uh
i'll show you this too this is this is
crazy
if i go into my
youtube page here
so if i look at my top like hogwarts
legacy videos like i just posted one a
couple days ago how evil can you be in
hogwarts legacy that one is already at
like 62 000 views which for my channel
is fantastic that's fantastic
i had another one um let's see
there was another one about the dark
arts i believe
[Music]
or did i have i not is that that might
be my first one on the dark arts anyway
though anytime i ever do a poll
it's like the dark arts are always huge
so i think it's a case of them knowing
their audience but now that we have seen
that side of things i feel like the next
big thing would be them showing the
other side
at least i would hope because in this
video right here
this is a video that i just put up
not that that's an ad
yes you have to watch ads on your own
youtube videos if you guys did not know
this
yeah it's crazy right look i'm signed
into my youtube account this is my video
and there yeah i'll skip the ads okay so
this is a video i just put out a couple
days before
and at the very end of this i say i
think the next thing that i want to try
and make a video on is what is going to
be the light side of things
what is going to be like if we i
personally think avada kadava is going
to be a finisher only type of spell
i don't think it's going to be something
that we can just go in and
there we go perfect timing right there i
don't think it's something we can cast
any time so then it's like what's the
equivalent
if you choose not to go the dark magic
path
is there like another spell that's the
equivalent for that or would you just
have to solve you have to to you know
complete that challenge in a different
way basically
[Music]
all right and then somebody was saying
so yeah apologies i missed your uh
missed your questions
chat is is flowing really fast tonight
two playthroughs mary absolutely for
sure mary
definitely
all right
please play harry potter and the goblet
of fire oh ray that's
i'm very close to the end of my uh
prisoner basketball play-through
and then i'm gonna have to do goblet of
fire even though that's probably one of
the worst ones
that's a lot of people's least favorite
jason don't think you just spam ak yeah
i don't think so
griffin ryan says he's a gryffindor but
doesn't want to play as one seems too
typical hey i can uh
i could see that 37 years old still love
harry potter ray i am almost right there
with you ray we are almost the exact
same age
[Music]
oh jay rossi what's up
if i get the game while i stream oh
absolutely yeah we're going to be doing
some streams
we're going to be doing live streams for
the game we're going to be doing um
i'm still undecided on because i want to
live stream it but then i also want to
have let's plays up too
and so you know what i think it's all
going to be live streams and then
they're going to be i'll bring them over
as let's plays
but yeah there's definitely going to be
be live streams
all right now somebody was saying i just
saw somebody said uh read the uh
oh yeah i didn't even think about this
the video description here
all right should you choose to befriend
slytherin student sebastian sallow you
will be faced with the decision to
embrace or reject the dark arts as you
uncover his family's mystery through his
companion quest line
will you choose to learn this dark magic
focusing on one of hogwarts legacy's
optional companion quest lines with
sebastian sallow
the dark legacy trailer provides a
glimpse at the forbidden curses
[Music]
curses
plural
did you guys sketch that
curse is plural
[Music]
and difficult dilemmas players will face
as they learn more about the sallow
family's mystery and decide whether to
engage with or even embrace
the dark arts
yo
always be the first to get hogwarts
legacy news at go.wbgames.com
wait is this like the official website i
don't think i've ever
okay yeah why didn't they just say
i hogwarts.com if they've updated the
faq or anything
[Music]
doesn't look like it
[Music]
it doesn't look like it
remove requirement online or co-op game
play
so yeah everybody who keeps thinking
there's still hope i mean i feel like
they're answering it about as bluntly as
they can right here
hogwarts legacy is a single player
experience
and does not have
[Music]
really like goblet of fire on ps2 man
usually that's the one i hear that
people uh
like the least
you can learn all three i think so too
i think so too
oh dylan wanting to know if a spinning
olivander quote
see i
i don't know i don't think i'm ready for
it yet i feel like it wouldn't
because this microphone
i'm using the microphone as an excuse
this microphone is a microphone that
requires you to be like right on top of
it so you guys probably like watch this
if i go
check check check one two one two one
two
[Music]
you're just not gonna be able to hear it
as well
but i do i we do have to come up with
something for those of you who are new
and like what the heck's he talking
about um another
hogwarts legacy youtuber that i love is
uh james of expect a go
and whenever his live streams hit i
think it's a hundred likes
dread yo thank you dread for the super
chat
please don't multiplayer it will take
away from the single player experience
love your streams man keep it up dred
thank you so much for the support and i
think we can rest easy if you were
worried about multiplayer i think
they're making it pretty clear that uh
it is not going to
have any multiplayer in hogwarts legacy
i personally would love to see it if it
was like a completely sort of separate
thing like i always use the example of
ghost of tsushima i think that's the
that's the blueprint for a game that has
a single player focus
but wants to get multiplayer right
i feel like that is definitely the model
for it because it was completely
separate
it was
totally different style and everything
hogwarts legacy leaks that's leaks with
two e's by the way what did you think of
the new
trailer
[Music]
i was i was uh i gave it an acceptable
in terms of the owl scoring system yeah
it didn't blow me away there were parts
i loved
and honestly it's like they just showed
us i think it's we were spoiled by the
gameplay reveal they showed us so much
there
um but i do love that they basically
confirmed crucio and i think in doing so
confirmed
[Music]
they didn't outright confirm imperio but
come on you're not gonna have it crucio
and avodakadavra and not have imperio as
well i think imperial will definitely be
in
so i like that i love that they're
showing off some of the dark vibes
um
and the fact that's
the the thing the best part about that
whole thing to me is that it's like
that's completely optional thing
which is nuts right
which is nuts that that's completely
optional thing
so you do not even have to go down the
path of that quest line
which then begs the question
how many other companions are there
how many other companions are there we
know for sure there are three we feel
pretty confident there's at least a
fourth because then that would give one
for each house are there more than that
we still don't know we still don't know
uh mary was asking if i'm gonna finish
i i beat
i beat the hogwarts cup in the quidditch
world cup game but then i don't think i
went all the way and beat the quidditch
world cup
yeah i kind of seen everything for the
game though i feel like which is why i
didn't i didn't go back to that one
would i choose to embrace the dark arts
not in my first playthrough no no not my
first playthrough aspect what are my
thoughts on what could be some of the
collector's edition items so i think for
sure
well we know 100
that it's going to have all this right
here it's at least going to have what
the digital deluxe edition includes it's
going to have the thestral mount it's
going to have the dark arts cosmetic set
dark arts battle arena
onyx hippogriff mount dark arts garrison
hat and the 72 hour early access so i
think you'll for sure get all of those
things
and then if the leaks were correct
and hey we have hogwarts legacy leaks in
here maybe they can let us know
maybe they can let us know
i want to pull back up that um oh no not
create a post
[Music]
i want to look up the old leak
for the collector's edition
[Music]
here it is
[Music]
so
okay yeah i thought so so we did not
the one thing that changed
okay so here was the leak right here
they said base game festival mount dark
arts cosmetic dark arts battle arena
so
dark arts cosmetic darkhearts battle
arena that that much was the same
thestral mount was the same
onyx hippogriff mount though
was not
in here oh and there's no kelpie robe
so see that's why i told you guys like
we can't take it as 100
back even when this was leaked and
everybody was kind of taking it as fact
i said hold on
it's legit like it is from that source
but
so they basically swapped out this might
have been an earlier plan they had a
kelpie robe
and then they took it out and instead
are doing the onyx hippogriff mount so
darkheart's garrison
the 72 hours early access so all of that
stayed the same so if this
is correct which as we just saw it's a
lot of it was but not
everything
base game destro mount dark arts
cosmetic dark arts battle arena dark
arts garrison 72 hours early access
kelpie robe
so i think instead of kelpie robe you
can go ahead and plug in onyx hippogriff
mount
because you're definitely gonna get all
this maybe get the kelp europe too
and then steel case and then floating
ancient magic wand with book i think it
would be awesome
if the kelpie robe was also something
physical
because it was it was weird how they
included it
when when this all leaked like the way
the code was set up all of the digital
stuff was together it's like all of this
and then these three were like like
wireless kelpy robe after
all of the other digital stuff
and see it ended up not being correct
right here
this did not end up being true
so maybe the kelpie robe is an actual
physical thing
[Music]
yeah could be adding the kelpie rope to
the collector's edition
[Music]
oh hi thank you so much for stopping by
hi enjoy your tv show i know what what
do you prefer me to call you i know you
told me once before
and i forgot it just sounds so weird to
say hi
hi
probably if if that's actually your name
that might be a different way to
pronounce it
uh yeah tomorrow tomorrow is the
official collector's edition reveal yeah
tomorrow at 9 00 a.m eastern time
that's when they're officially revealing
the collector's edition tomorrow
heading out to jason a have a good night
jason thank you for stopping by
jake okay i gotta try to remember that
hi equals jake hi jake
maybe if i can remember hi jake
but yeah i appreciate you guys stopping
by have a good one
[Music]
you're a wizard harry hogwarts legacy
leaks subscribing to the channel hey
thank you for subbing subbing to the
channel there
[Music]
what about the guys on the train in the
first
trailer maybe those professors become
companions as well
uh well we know fig the other guy i have
no idea who that other guy is
no idea who the other guy is cameron
says thank you for doing this hey
cameron thank you for hanging out
appreciate it
want the wallpaper so bad you mean like
this right here right
oh dude have they not released that yet
i forgot i didn't even think about
checking the media
oh come on chandler
like chandler's the only one who does
this
taylor come on get these wallpapers up
dude yes we 100
we need a wallpaper of
this right here
oh my gosh we need that as a wallpaper
[Music]
and then somebody was saying the first
see i
j rossi and several others have
commented about
us being on a train in the first trailer
and i have watched that trailer so many
times
and to me it feels like they're on the
carriage
[Music]
or wait no you guys aren't talking about
the first trailer you're talking about
the second trailer i believe
yeah
the gameplay trailer
okay stay to play gameplay trailer yeah
this one here
yeah let's see it's i'm pretty sure i
know the scene you're talking about
where
where is he where's our boy
where's our boy fig
it's whenever fig and ran rock and the
daily pro yeah right here
i don't think that's a train
is this for people who say that the
scene with the train
jay rossi if you're still in here and
then whoever else just said this about
the train that i feel like they're in
the sky right there
see the outside i feel like they're in
the carriage they're in the flying
carriage
[Music]
yeah i don't think that's in the train i
think that's the carriage that they
arrive in at hogwarts
unless there's a different scene you
guys are talking about
[Music]
hogwarts legacy league says the
collector edition is very good
we'll see
[Music]
yeah i don't think that's the train
is that the one you guys were talking
about let's see who was it that said
forget it's not a train flying carriage
[Music]
carriage had a bunch of books and
suitcases yeah i think you see those
right there
on the back
[Music]
i think that's the very same one they
arrive in
i don't think we ever see a shot of the
train
or of a train
[Music]
yeah because they're definitely like in
the clouds
okay
we gotta all right let's we haven't done
our breakdown yet
we have not done our our deep dive on
the new trailer
so
i'm gonna i'm gonna go
because i i've got so many videos i need
oh we got plenty of time okay good i was
thinking all right
let me cut our music
because i want to start actually going
through this with you guys here
you guys have had a chance to watch it a
lot more than i have already
so you're probably gonna find things
that i
have missed
[Music]
all right so let's pause our music
alright so
i've already watched the trailer through
a couple of times
now
is our deep dive guys now it's time to
do a deep dive on the brand new hogwarts
legacy trailer sebastian sallow's dark
legacy
in glorious glorious 4k here with you
guys all right so let's start it off
here
now you guys are going to get an inside
look at
the more we know about salazar slytherin
okay the more
we're get i mean we're going to take it
all in the more we know about salazar
slytherin and then we immediately get a
shot of
the screenshot that they already shared
leading up to this but it's a slightly
different view
so oh man it's not going to let me zoom
in
darn it
i really need to be able to zoom in on
this right here
actually let's see does youtube give you
any tools to do that no they do not oh
darn it well we'll be able to zoom in
later but a lot of this i think we've
seen already um this is like the beware
spiders danger that sort of thing and
what appears to be the forbidden forest
what appears to be the forbidden forest
we don't know that for sure that's not a
100 confirmation all right so let's
listen to what he says again
the more we know about salazar slytherin
and the dark arts
the more we know about salazar slytherin
and the dark arts the best prepared will
be
the better prepared will be so it
honestly it doesn't even sound like
sebastian is a
bad guy necessarily
slytherin and the dark arts it just
sounds like he's wanting to learn more
about the dark arts
and he thinks that's going to better
prepare him for
something we don't know exactly what
that is all right so
first reaction at this i feel like this
is going to be something that we find
in the forbidden forest
and i believe this is going to be a
dungeon of sorts and this right here we
can clearly see a little symbol
but we can't clearly see what the symbol
is we can clearly see the symbol but we
can't quite make it out from here i
wouldn't be surprised if it snakes if
it's something to do with salazar
slytherin
especially since that is who he's
talking about right here we have the
stones around
i'm sure people will be saving all this
and
changing up the exposure so we can
actually see more of the trees here see
what's going on
but yeah anything else in this shot
we've got a wizard right here we've got
a body right here and a body right here
i'm guessing in fury
maybe it was being guarded by inferior
we also know that acromantula were
commonly used they were first bred
mainly to be as a guard of some sort of
hidden treasure for wizards
so that would make sense that we're
going to encounter those on our way here
we do still need an explanation for how
these acromantula got there
um
in my video earlier this week about the
dark arts in hogwarts legacy and or no
in my video about the spiders i don't
think it would break cannon to have
spiders here
because aragog never says that he was
the first spider in the forest he never
says that so a lot of people have been
saying that but that's that's not what
he says hagrid did find him a wife and
it kind of implies that maybe hagrid had
to find the wife from outside the forest
but we don't know if something happened
that could have wiped them out or not
they could have been wiped out or most
ag aragog's wife may have been found in
the forest
for hagrid may have just went and found
her there we don't know but we know that
they did not
that's not where they originate from so
something has to happen to bring the
spiders there
we got the story in the harry potter
series about how that colony of spiders
got there
or they could be different type of
spiders they may not be exactly
acromantula but i think it would make
sense and i don't think it would break
the cannon there
all right let's move forward here
the best prepared will be
if i
okay then we get a shot right here
of clearly now they've made their way
inside
this dungeon
and it looks like so yeah it's the same
two characters throughout we've got
sebastian here so maybe sebastian was
waiting on us and then the player
character who in this trailer is a
hufflepuff
uh and we've got the candles here
looking very reminiscent of the candles
that we see in the movies
uh then we have what looks like the
youtube uh
the little slide bar right there is kind
of covering it up maybe another inferior
down here
and we've got the flames here we've got
more symbols here along these columns
we've got some what appear to be coffins
down here
i mean
just the vibes and i mean this looks
like something out of uh dark souls game
right walking down into a one of those
deep caverns
either of you uses dark magic i will
notify the headmaster immediately
if either of you uses dark magic i will
notify the headmaster dark magic
best prepared will be listen to him
again if either of you uses dark magic i
will notify the headmaster immediately
notify the headmaster immediately so
that kind of makes me think that as a
teacher and the gamekeeper would fit
i've seen a couple people thinking that
it's the gamekeeper
yeah i could definitely see that
could definitely see that so now it
seems like they're still kind of making
their way through here
got these rock formations over here it's
all so dark i'm gonna have to go and
lighten up a lot of this when i oh is
that like just a
is that a brief glimpse of another one
of those like plates
see if this
ah it doesn't it doesn't show enough of
it
let's go back
pro tip on youtube guys if you use the
uh
oh what is that apostrophe
no it's whatever
whatever is right next to your m key to
the right of the m
if you hit that it'll just go frame by
frame
okay so we can go to the very last frame
right here
all right so i'm trying to see if
there's any other symbols or anything
we've got a little bit of lighting down
here this kind of green
on these little uh i don't know if that
means those are items you can interact
with possibly
but then right here this this looks like
some sort of
circular formation
right there circular formation
unforgivable curses are
so named
for a reason
unforgivable curses are so named
for a reason
unforgivable curses i mean that's
that's gotta be slytherin right
i'm thinking that's salazar slytherin
right there
and is that the same statue that we see
that we already saw in the other trailer
a different version of it
i mean i guess it could be merlin too
but
since the focus of this trailer is on
slytherin i'm thinking this is
definitely slytherin right here
thinking this is definitely slytherin
hey we got mrs weasley in the chat as
well mrs weasley what's up
welcome
mary says thinking the caretaker maybe a
caretaker could be possible
although he does seem to be
oh see that's what i forget like with
filch
the caretaker doesn't have to be a squib
so i think in my head i was thinking
there's no way he'd be the caretaker
because
he's clearly he has a knowledge of magic
but there's there's no reason that he
couldn't be the caretaker and also
someone who knows magic i think that was
just a unique situation for filch in
harry potter's day
snake head to the left let's see
my lights for the oh yeah
there you go
my lights from my uh for my camera are
shining on me right there it's kind of
making that hard to see over on the left
yeah so i'm i'm feeling pretty confident
this is salazar slytherin right here
are so named
for a reason all right yeah talking
about unforgivables they're so named for
a reason
oh that's what you guys were talking
about possible deathly hallows symbol
right there
i mean what else would it be right
you can clearly see the triangle clearly
see the circle but i don't see i don't
see the wand
i do not see the symbol of the wand
we've got some more runes here and here
i guarantee some of those match up with
some of the ones we've seen
in the other trailers already
so then this right on the head of the
skull here
which what the heck is that even a human
skull is it a human skull and just
missing the jaw
i have no idea
getting chamber of secrets
head vibes from the statue yeah
definitely
that's a good point mary it looks a lot
like the slytherin statue from chamber
of secrets the one in the movies for
sure
right i can't think of what else it
could be even though i don't see the
wand let me play it a little bit more
maybe
ah doesn't show you any more of it
wishful thinking right
all right going frame by frame here
come on come on
oh my goodness i didn't think i went
that far forward
okay
yeah i mean maybe it's just like we just
can't quite see it from here or maybe
maybe they remove the wand from the
from the trailer so we wouldn't figure
it out but
i mean yeah i just can't think of what
else it could be
even though you don't really see or i
mean it could be just a totally new
symbol something uh
something else entirely
all right how about this shot right here
spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable
a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable sebastian says
for a reason
a spell that could save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable the dark
hearts seem harmless until it's too late
so i wonder which one
if he's talking about a specific one or
he just means like hey if you're in a
life or death situation
and you got to use
an unforgivable to get out of it then it
should be fair game for a reason
a spell okay right here
dude that looks like a skull of the
dragon that we've seen so many times the
habridian black
because look at the
i mean i guess that's still called a
horn right on on the side right here
then we've got the rat right here as
well i noticed that one pretty quickly
several different thestrals here
thestral here here and here we've got
some birds flying here
and then we we also have a shot in one
of the other trailers where we fly
through
and see that scene of the bones right
here
but
this
i don't know it could just be a
different angle the bones look very
similar right here
but i do not remember seeing any of that
right there
do not remember seeing any of that
well that could save your life shouldn't
be unforgivable then we start to get
into the beware spiders again
so these are
clearly they're going to have these
beware spiders extreme danger signs
leading up to
this dungeon that we're going in
so beware spiders extreme danger
the dark hearts seem harmless
dude this is crazy right here
this shot is just crazy we'll be able to
avoid dark magic forever
harmless until it's too late
harmless until it's too late so clearly
this was this forgivable
the dark hearts seem harmless until it's
too late is this somebody we're like
trying to rescue right here
that the spiders have taken captive
life shouldn't be unforgivable
the dark hot
we've got kind of this reddish glow
right here i'm wondering what's going on
with that the giant web
right here
seem
harmless it's too late
none of us will be able to oh man what a
great shot right there
as it's zooming out
boy dark magic forever
what do we do now
it's up to us
i can teach you crucio
or i can cast it on you what do we do
now i can teach you crucio or i can cast
it on you
wow okay let me back up again
because
i want to make sure we talk about this
magic
here okay
more snakes so this must be like they
must
be sort of playing this as another
dungeon another area made by salazar
slytherin or perhaps something made in
homage to him like that another wizard
made at some point
because i mean the snakes and the statue
of what we're pretty sure is slytherin
it's just all over the place so i think
the big question is did he build it
when he built like something like the
chamber of secrets or was it built by
somebody else in his honor
let's see catch up with some of the
comments here
put subs on the video mate um
what do you mean put subs on the video
i'm not sure what you're talking about
put subs on the video
hit 27k yo let's go thank you mrs
weasley for the congrats appreciated
mary says right on the edge of the
beware spiders it looks like part of a
spider
let's go back and see
beware
too late
hope is right before that
life shouldn't be
unforgivable oh yeah yeah right there at
the bottom left yeah you can see one day
none of us will be able to avoid dark
magic forever
what do we do now
what do we do now and then oh
and then it has crucio etched on
the floor here
clearly i think it oh subtitles okay
okay
gotcha i was like subs
do i not have subs turned on
all right so crucio thank you guys for
the clarification cruzio on the floor
clearly i think that is indicating that
that is how we pass like that's how we
get in
it's up to us i can teach you crucio
or i can cast it on you
dude and then you get like that the
camera pans back
she starts to have this like panicked
look
clearly we've seen this in a number of
games this is like that moment when
you're about to be presented with the
choice right if they let this play out
we would have seen it pop up of like
what are you going to decide basically
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
the subtitles are kind of blocking it
right there
i'm ready
oh my goodness
yeah so as soon as they cast it on each
other i bet that is what opens up
i'm ready that door
you've made your choice
you have made your choice
you've made your choice
and then we got the inferior their model
has changed a little bit
and they are looking creepy let me say
cree b
so yeah that's
i think that is how you if you want to
complete this quest and still
participate but not
go down the dark path then
you have to be like all right i'll
sacrifice myself you can basically
torture me here to get in
oh and then we get a nice shot of her
fighting off the
and fury okay we got a couple of action
shots right here
[Music]
let's back up
again you've made your choice
who is that talking
you've made your choice
that that sounds like somebody that we
haven't heard yet i don't know if it's
meant to be the player character and
this is like while maybe if she chose to
have crucio cast
oh man and this is like her while she's
suffering
that's kind of dark right
so then we get more inferior and then we
get a nice little shot
i'm going to slow this one down right
here
so we can watch this in slow-mo
oh hold on i don't want the audio there
so yeah definitely incendio oh dude that
is sick
more incendio being cat or no oh
i don't know that was a little bit wider
of a of a net right there
dude that is so awesome i'm gonna back
up again
get a nice look at the inferior
man i really just want to see gameplay
though i want to see
how it looks like in game when you're
when you're the character doing this
right here this is what i want to see
more of all right and then this looks
like one of those dark wizards
got the top out here and then i this
part is unclear to me i don't know if
we're jumping to a new scene here
or if this is still in i mean clear
we're jumping to a new scene i don't
know if this is a new setting oh it has
to be right because we've got this lamp
post here we've got the light
oh you think that's rookwood amir
possibly confringo that's yeah it could
definitely be confringo as well
all right i'm gonna put it back at
normal speed and then i wanna let me
turn the sound back on
all right so let me back up here
that right there you guys think it's
liquid
oh yeah we're really gonna have to slow
this down we get a lot right here at the
end
oh dude that is so crazy
oh no okay too much is happening all
right we gotta slow down we gotta go
back
okay so we got that part right there and
then uh we see protego again but yeah i
think this is
this right about here i think we've
transitioned
i think we're outside somewhere look at
that another cage looks like
honestly it looks like one for the owls
but then also some sort of is that like
a trebuchet or some sort of catapult
right there
and then over on the left we've got some
red right here i'm not sure if that's
blood or
some kind of paint
so we get a nice ooh i love that get
protego to block
and then retaliating
then we go back to sebastian
here
the book behind him right there
okay lots happening right there but
looks like yeah i need to slow it down
again
i need to slow it down again
this is at .25 speed oh yeah and then i
love this right here is that
over here on the right i guess that's
still sebastian
it just looks it looks kind of different
in the with the dark shadow on him there
and then clear i mean this like this
just totally reminds you of chamber of
secrets right which this to me would
indicate that
maybe they're going with the that
slytherin built this
oh but then do you guys think we need
parcel tongue to get inside
no this one this one we get inside with
oh or is this a completely different
door
because we know we got into that
previous door my guess is by using
crucio man that would be a crazy way so
for like chamber of secrets he made it
where you had to be a parcel mouth to
get in there
here you have to cast crucio to get in
and then this section right here i
wonder if it's crucio again or if it's
something different
or if it's parcel mouth
get the door opening right there
oh and then this shot right here i
really i want to make sure we slow this
one down i mean that is
terrifying maybe this is at the end of
this dungeon
you have stairs
made of skulls and bones which these
definitely appear to be
human right here oh
maybe these are like all the people who
have tried and failed
oh dude and you can like see stuff under
here in between too
then it goes to the player character
heading into another okay this room
right here okay so i definitely think
those shots are connected so it looks
like she was coming from uh from
underground right here
we've got more of these
so many spider webs in here so i guess
we're going to be encountering even more
spiders
once we get inside dude look at the
reflections
look at the reflections right here
fred come on retro
i do want to sleep tonight sorry
i know right
this dude this dungeon is creepy there
is no doubt about that
look at all these spiderwebs
oh dude you know there's just gonna be a
massive spider boss at the end of this
dungeon
you just know
we got more inferior right here oh we
got the runes again that is like the uh
the archer one that we saw
i think in relation to a centaur is
where we previously saw that in another
trailer
and then this right here
that looks like that could be an uh a
slytherin statue
i see a beard right there and then it
looks like they're holding something
holding some sort of symbol there as
well
and then right here we have looks like
nothing special just a regular vase
right here
looks like just a regular vase
all right let's go forward a little bit
more here
i can't believe they showed um
the mentors in that little key art but
we don't see them here in the trailer at
all i was really hoping we'd see some
dementors
oh dude i love that we have a that is a
totally different type of troll than
what we've seen before
look at the design on this guy
back up a little bit more
oh wait he just attacked uh
he just attacked the inferior
look at that
okay he gets ready
he takes the swing right there
i'm not sure what's going on right here
that's supposed to be like a hit
detection thing
he just knocks that inferior out of the
way so it seems like
the troll here oh dude
okay
what's going on here
why is the contr the
why is the troll seemingly targeting the
inferior
unless the player is right behind them
oh my gosh i just had an insane thought
dude so
for any of you if you know the lore of
inferi
they are not a natural occurrence they
have to be created
by a dark wizard
so i wonder if
dude you don't think we
at some point
no
right no
you don't think we at some point are the
ones who create somebody in theory
oh my gosh or or
this could be an imperious curse
situation
this could be an imperius curse
situation
yes you're exactly right i see somebody
in the chat saying maybe we're
controlling the troll
this could be an imperial situation
where we're in control of the troll
or
wait can you imperio an inferior
i don't think so because they're they're
dead so yeah it would be it would be a
different spell
but either way like we could be using
dark arts to control
one of the two right here
okay that's super interesting though or
i mean it could just be a simple
environmental thing like maybe our
character is standing like right behind
the inferior and the troll is just
lunging at us and the inferior just
happens to be there but the part that's
weird about it is that he it does the
big swing first hits the inferior and
then he he like proceeds to hit the
inferior again
all right let's move forward a little
bit more okay yeah let's turn let's turn
the sound back on
and let's go back up to normal speed
me back it up
what have the two of you done
and that's it right there
what have the two of you done so clearly
something goes wrong
and clearly this gentleman here finds
out oh and he is in there at this point
so it looks like he's going to
follow us or
he's kind of keeping a close watch on
things
not expecting that we're gonna make the
right choice here love you
oh they're panicked now yeah they know
something
they know something is bad wrong at this
point
oh my goodness dude
oh february 10th or february 7th
for the pre-order for the pre-order of
the digital deluxe and almost assuredly
the collector's edition as well
that was super interesting that deep
dive right there
wow let me know what you guys think down
in the comments below
i'll post that later as a separate video
let me know what you guys think here in
the live stream as well i'll go back
through and catch some of these comments
that i missed as we were going through
there and now we can go through the more
i'm going to make sure i didn't miss any
of the text you guys were asking for me
to put on the
subtitles there i think i got everything
more we know about salazar slytherin and
the dark arts better prepared will be
if he ever uses dark magic we'll notify
the headmaster immediately
unforgivable curses are so named for a
reason
a spell that can save your life
shouldn't be unforgivable
i think he just means like in a life or
death scenario the dark hearts seem
harmless until it's too late none of us
will be able to doctor
ever that's sebastian saying that it's
up to us i can teach you crucio
or i can cast it on you
i'm ready
okay that's really turned on though yeah
so that's a different door that is not
the same door as the one with the snakes
on it and i also want to see what shows
up behind her
oh so yeah whenever whenever the camera
pulls back behind cost is
behind her on the left here yeah you see
the door right there
so clearly they're still kind of hiding
some of the in-game elements
they're not showing us what the choice
will look like here like how we decide
oh man
that's crazy
all right i'll pause it right there let
me turn the music back on and then i'll
get to some of your your feedback here
some of your comments
see what you guys are thinking here
all right let me scroll up i don't know
if that's rookwood i saw somebody
mentioning rookwood what do you guys
think
[Music]
looks almost like gameplay yeah it
that's like that's my biggest ask at
this point
that is what i want to see
i just want to see gameplay i liked i
enjoyed the trailer it's a good trailer
and the thing is now with the with them
not releasing till um
february they still have plenty of time
so before when we were thinking the
game's releasing early december
it was kind of like oh man you guys you
guys really gotta show a little bit more
here
but um
now they got a little bit more time so
i'm not i'm not worried about that
i think they have plenty of time to show
us some other things i think they have
plenty of time to show us um maybe some
more of the good path
the light side
um if we choose not to go down the dark
arts path
hey we got victor rookwood in the chat
as well
carol the streamer do i think any of the
actors from the movies will lend their
voice to a character for this game ah
i didn't think about that
i did not think about that i i doubt it
i feel like they want this to kind of
stand on its own
but that would be cool though especially
for like a little cameo but if i mean
well we already know nearly headless
nick it's definitely not
john cleese i feel like that would have
i don't think it's
well we hear him talk and i'm pretty
sure it's not john cleese
if we created in fury that would be wild
right mary like
because clearly in that scene the troll
is going after
the troll is going after the inferior
for some reason
[Music]
oh we got a dev here in the chat
[Music]
if you have to say you're a dev you're
likely not hey you never know
it's pronounced infernai
definitely not
definitely in theory
[Music]
there's a third person that appears in
the scene at the same time oh you got a
time stamp for that one
i did not see a third person
you can use all three curses uh jonathan
blake says use all three curses to get
to the final room which contains merlin
puzzle that once solved allows you to
make horcruxes horcruxes boost health by
times three
what
what
that would be insanity
that is sebastian's dad was so is
sebastian's dad also a hogwarts
professor
yeah yeah fred i'm
it's it's in theory yeah
[Music]
i know sorting hat the lighting is so
good the reflections
yeah reflections were really nice too
awesome i am so hyped
jay rossi walking the light path but
loving the dark vibes of the trailer
yeah that's that's where i'm at rossi
that is where i'm at
what do you think we can do after the
story
hey i definitely think they will
make it so we can still roam the castle
and so we can still
go through and complete all of our
um
like any sort of side activities that we
want to
okay wait hold on i gotta investigate
this somebody's saying that on reddit
gamestop has re has leaked the
collector's edition and then it's 300
bucks
[Music]
let us see here
[Music]
i mean we only have like
less than 12 hours now to find out guys
for sure
[Music]
but
i will look for it because
if it shows what's in it that would be
pretty awesome
oh dude
[Music]
you are not kidding i think this is
legit you guys i think
i think this is legit
all right if you don't want to see it
look away but i'm gonna show what i
think is
the collector's edition for hogwarts
legacy
so apparently this was leaked by eb
games australia
oh my goodness
so dark arts pack which is what we
already saw in the digital collectors
edition
steel case and full game
oh my gosh please be legit i really hope
it does include both the
steel case and the regular case please
please include both
then we have floating wand life size
with book base
wait
what
collector's edition box also includes
kelpie robe oh so the kelpie robe is not
a
a kelpie robe is also a digital thing 72
hour early access dark arts garrison hat
i feel like this is legit i mean even if
it's not this is a pretty good mock-up
from somebody based on what is
been leaked already
dude
so
floating wand life size with book base
wait is this like one of those things
that actually like
oh you've seen them they have various
like um like you see these these light
bulbs that people have i don't even know
what the base is called but where they
will actually like hover
is that
is that what this is
because if that's what this is that
would be incredible
and then what is up with this wand dude
not the elder wand
like what is this this sort of like
extra
[Music]
something like kind of twisting around
it
dude what if it's like merlin's wand
oh and it does say pc down here
oh my gosh but no switch
you guys think they're not gonna do
what if they do not have a switch
collector's edition it does have xbox
one it does have pc it does have xbox
series x
does have ps4 does have ps5
and then it looks like the cover is the
same cover now
this
on collector's edition stuff guys
it is also um it's a big deal whether or
not based on your territory sometimes
there are differences between different
territories so it's important to know
this is 100
not confirmed this was from a this was
just posted about 10 minutes ago on the
harry potter game subreddit hogwarts
legacy collector edition has been
revealed eb games australia this is just
a screenshot i have no way of uh
verifying it looks like the reddit mods
have looked into it and said not
technically an official announcement but
all the information lines up with stuff
we have seen and eb games is a credible
source keep in mind some of this
information could be outdated and
correct hope that price is inaccurate
though where is the price
am i missing the price
i know they said 300
hey i don't see the price unless it's
like super fine is there another page
yeah i'm not seeing the price
[Music]
499.
wait what
what is that currency
[Music]
oh my gosh dude
i want to see i
oh
i really need to know more about this
does it actually like hover
does it actually hover and can i flip
through the book or is this just like a
set
a set piece
okay i've got to go to
money
wizard money conversion
i have no idea what no not us dollars
um australia
australian dollar
[Music]
so that'd be 345 euros
[Music]
dude where is the
where's the u.s dollar
340
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh man no art book though and no
no soundtrack
that's a little bit surprising
classic what's up thank you for stopping
by won't be able to flip that is where
the magnet is to keep it hovering and
the wand is meant to dude that's what
i'm hoping
but that is that's going to be oh man
i love i love this i said i didn't want
to wand if they did a collection edition
but something like this i think would be
pretty cool
steel case is cool
including the regular game box is cool
including a physical copy
also cool
but come on we need i feel like they
need one more
either the art book or
i would say art book and the um
[Music]
the soundtrack
in stores february 7th because yeah
it would make sense if you're buying
this one then you get the 72 hours early
access
[Music]
is this the article george is this the
one you were talking about
do i want the one i know the wand is so
awesome
[Music]
yeah
i think
if this is 300
how would they be just okay so
70 bucks for the game
let's give them the let's add this up
here let's give them the benefit of the
doubt 70 bucks for the game
[Music]
so 70 for the game let's say
i'll even say 15 for the steel book
which
steel case is not worth 15 but we'll
just say it is and then the dark arts
pack let's see that's three things there
three digital things and then kelpie
robes 72 hours early access dark arts
garrison hat
i'll even give them another let's say
another 25 dollars for that
so 85 plus 25
so that's a hundred and ten dollars
[Music]
so that means that for the floating wand
that's basically a hundred and ninety
dollars
deluxe is 79.99 is that confirmed like
next like so like
ps5 because that would mean that they're
only saying it's um
if that if what demonic one just posted
is true
that would mean that they're only
valuing this at about ten dollars
which the i mean
if that's the case like
100 this is not worth it
at most yeah like
[Music]
oh wait hold on hold on hold on
george is saying that
google game spot hogwarts like z
collector's edition
all right let's try this
or gamestop
hogwarts legacy collectors
edition
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hold on what did you say to do after
that because i'm not seeing it
wait where'd you go george where did you
go
okay google game spot
i'm pretty sure you mean game stop
hogwarts legacy collectors
or wait you just said hogwarts legacy
collectors that's it okay that's what i
just searched
and then
let's see next step
if you see this comment what you're
looking at is not oh yeah yeah
scroll down until you see a game oh wait
game spot okay you i was you were
correct
oh yeah here it is four hours ago
pre-orders are live
[Music]
scrolling until you see a gamespot
article with the title okay i found that
gamespot article
[Music]
and then is there a
[Music]
watch unboxing on youtube august 24th
[Music]
oh i bet that's what's going live
tomorrow is there gonna be unboxing
[Music]
i still don't see
i think they've taken down if they had a
pre-order link they've taken it down
oh wait right here
oh
just takes you to their youtube page
yeah and then if you hit this watch
unboxing
290 to 300 hogwarts look at this pricey
collector's edition hasn't been shown
off yet but it will be unboxed on the
official youtube channel okay so i don't
think we had confirmation i mean they
said showing off but
it comes with all of the deluxe edition
content and the following goodies
life-size floating ancient magic one
with book bass
steelbook case kelpie robe
oh
[Music]
um
you guys know i keep it real with you
man i'm gonna be honest
that's too pricey
that's too pricey it needs to include uh
it needs to include the art book and it
needs to include the
soundtrack for that price
it will sell don't get me wrong it'll
sell
yeah and then yeah yeah exactly uh
classic yeah right there's where they i
mean that could just be speculation i
don't know if but i would think they
how are they just
dude
eighty dollars just for this
like i don't get the jump
okay so
going let's go by their own
metrics here
so they're saying
80. so hogwarts legacy is saying 80
for
the game
the dark arts pack
the 72 hours early access
the dark arts garrison hat
they're saying all that for eighty
dollars
that's what they're charging if if all
this is correct by the way if all this
is correct remember that part
so they're saying 80 for that
so then all you're adding on with the
collector's edition is you're adding on
the steel case you're adding on the
kelpie robe which is a digital item
and then you're adding the floating wand
with book base
so they're saying that the flo they're
saying all of that
is
128. no
no
they're saying that's true wait
what
if it ends up being 300
i was like the math in my head has to be
220 dollars
for the floating wand and the steel case
what
[Music]
oh man
okay let's let's compare let's compare
i want to compare it to the god of war
ragnarok
collectors editions
which i'm pretty sure they're all
sold out but surely i can find somewhere
that
oh come on
[Music]
okay this was their
god of war ragnarok collectors edition
[Music]
oh yeah so the god of war ragnarok
collector's edition says that um
[Music]
oh the the yodnar edition
was only 229
[Music]
and that's the bigger
dude there's no way they're gonna be
charging 300 for this please be
like 200 would be so much more
reasonable
please please be a placeholder
please be a placeholder
[Music]
okay hold on i want to show you guys
what you
want to show you what you would get
[Music]
so the god of war
okay so this right here was the god of
war
ragnarok collector's edition
all of this right here was 199.
you get the steelbook you get this
these two things here you get all the
digital stuff you get the dice set and
you get the hammer
then the yodnar edition
this one right here
is 260 us dollars
dude there's no oh my gosh they're gonna
catch so
if they're charging 300 for this they're
gonna catch so much heat
they're gonna catch so much heat if they
charge 300 for this
so youtun are apparently on the
playstation direct was 259.99
and it includes the seven-inch vinyl
falcon bear and wolf pin set
the legendary
drop near
ring
brock's dice set xracial cloth map
kratos and then all the the digital
stuff the hammer
i'm just gonna say plea maybe they got a
that first digit wrong and that it's two
and not a three
[Music]
dude two yeah okay i mean it's point i i
should i feel like i shouldn't even
speculate because we're gonna find out
in less than 12 hours
[Music]
look up the levitating snitch it's 200
no way
oh my gosh demonic one
[Music]
levitating snitch dude i bet you it's
like the same tech
he was not kidding
bradford exchange i've never heard of
this website but
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
two i would not pay 220 for this
just four interest-free installments of
55
i wonder if that's where they got the
pricing
[Music]
oh my gosh man
[Music]
testing out the new emoji
jake right
hi jake everyone's credit card
statements
oh man
black falcon said a long time no way
crucio in the game glad to be wrong
i can't believe that there's actually a
levitating snitch though that's that's
220.
[Music]
yeah i feel like it's got to be
placeholder
hopefully man hopefully
because i will say like for the for the
main item i actually really love this i
think that's really awesome
so i got to give them props on that
no doubt
but dude i'll do a full video on it once
we once we have it all confirmed
but
yeah we'll see
we'll see
[Music]
make a legit wand at home for almost
nothing
oh you see you said that the younger
edition was 2.99 huh i don't know what
this price that i was i mean even if so
the yonah edition included way more
than what if this is correct than what
the hogwarts legacy one
is including
yeah i agree logan i think 200 would be
very reasonable
because that would essentially mean
a hundred and twenty dollars for
the uh steel case the floating wand
and the kelpie rope which is an in-game
item
in the box i mean we can't really see
too much about the box that box is going
to be huge
and i would even feel much better about
it the 300 if it included like the uh
the uh
soundtrack or the art book
[Music]
white wolf said maybe the collector's
box has the arbitrage in it but they
were better at keeping them secret
possibly but man this looks this looks
like an official
ad right here from
from eb
[Music]
john would consider a fair price if you
could flip through the book and it's a
full-on spell book
rather that instead of the floating
feature honestly the one doesn't look i
know i want to see more about the wand
because the wand looked much better in
i just saw another picture of the wand
somewhere where was it
and it looked a lot better than what's
there
might have been this right here
[Music]
yeah that like that right there
wait why can i not why are you not
zooming in
[Music]
that right there you can almost see this
kind of like ornate
pattern on it
[Music]
that makes it look a little bit nicer i
think
and then i guess if you get the
collectors you're getting a wizard this
game box
yo thank you for subbing to the channel
just
appreciate it
no price has been confirmed exactly
exactly phantom we're all just
this is all just me reacting to
something that somebody said in the chat
and then we found it on reddit so this
is all just reacting in real time
[Music]
i'm i'm calling i'm saying no way
on that
300
i shouldn't say no way
i shouldn't say no way
gotham knights is
450
what
what the heck are they including in that
professor drew in game one i'm calling
it
oh 299 okay i was like
i was like what are they including for
450 you better be getting like a full
batman suit replica that you can wear
that you can wear
oh my goodness man
[Music]
want collectors but it's not digital oh
you got like a if you yeah dude if it's
see i'll be honest i prefer having the
physical copy of the game because as a
collector i just i feel like that's
but
i feel like they should also think about
the people who have digital only
consoles you know
because there's a lot of those out there
now
if you have a series s or if you have a
ps5
uh digital model
[Music]
it'd be cool if they could let you
choose but i don't know how they would
work that out the logistics of it
without you getting both
get it for 2.99 while you can scalpels
will sell it for a hund a thousand
got faith in wb avalanche they'll do
this right hey i hope so classic yeah
300 just feels a little steep
i mean i
as a channel covering it i still feel
like i would have to buy it just because
i
i would have to make content for you
guys on it to show show you what it
looks like in person
oh man
well that was cool that we got that info
here
that was cool that we got that
we'll see if it ends up being legit
[Music]
jason thank you for stopping by man have
a good night
[Music]
would it be weird to give out the
physical copy of the game 72 hours
before the actual release that's what it
said for the uh for the collectors if
that eb ad leak was real was legit it
said
in stores february 7th
so that would mean that the collector's
edition would be
in your hands
um
three days prior and will be in stores
[Music]
buying the collection edition for any
version as fast as i can click buy
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
yeah that's a tough thing they still
need to figure out about the whole
digital
uh your your point reese hey thank you
for the sub
your point reese about digital gaming
storefronts they're getting better but
yeah it's still not
still not 100 there and you never know
when support can just
can just
die you know and all of a sudden a game
that you i mean that's that's pretty
rare but it does happen it does happen
[Music]
uh let's see jake said what do you who
do you think
harmony should have
oh hermione should have dated harry or
ron i thought harry just finished
watching all the movies for the third
time
dude i'm not getting into that pandora's
box that is a big harry potter debate
right there
i will say book jenny
book jenny is
just like
such a more
a stronger character and makes so much
more sense than the movies
in the books it made a lot more sense
i'll say that much if if you've only
watched the movies then i can get why
people would be like wait
harry doesn't end up with hermione
it's not even a known one the book will
probably be static so not good at all
yeah i know gabriel i'm trying not to
get too down about it we'll see we'll
see once uh
once it's official and once we get a
price and everything
[Music]
the green looks awesome yeah i think so
i love this this sort of dark dark
edition cover that has the green
which please let us they need to release
this as a wallpaper
asap
asap we need this as a wallpaper
chandler
oh dude gaming age is reporting that too
299.
[Music]
oh my gosh
wait 289 for pc
pc gets a 10 cheaper okay
[Music]
oh
yeah 300 is too much
yeah the box art has the the mentors on
there
well this whole thing
is a slightly different version of the
cover art that we've gotten very
familiar with it's a slightly different
version of it
[Music]
yeah i did talk about the god of war
when gabriel yeah i mean that
i mean i gotta be honest you get you
just get so much more in the god of war
one
so much more
they're still saying nintendo switch
launch date will be revealed soon
so
soon
yeah i get the i get the next gen the
extra 10 but like pc is not included in
the
[Music]
it's like ps5 copies are going to cost
more than pc that's interesting
gotham knights 300 console pc is cheaper
dude and pc will probably i mean
as long as everything goes okay with the
with their
you know i i don't know how avalanche is
on getting game running games on pc but
i mean theoretically the pc version
should be the superior version
especially if the uh
especially if the dual sense
is compatible like obviously it's
compatible but will you get the special
dual sense features that you'll get on
ps5
[Music]
yeah
exactly like pc is always next gen
so it's like
how is sony how are they all getting
getting by with charging the extra ten
dollars
whatever i mean hey better
good for pc players right
[Music]
good for pc players
it's like it's going to be digital yeah
that's what a lot of people are saying
like digital the deluxe version seems
like the version the way to go which
i'll be honest with you like the deluxe
is only 10 bucks 10 extra bucks
if if what we've seen if the leaks are
correct
so basically 10 bucks
i mean let's be real here the big one
you're paying for is the early access
i would assume we don't know this for
sure but i would assume that you'll be
able to unlock all of this stuff right
here in game naturally because they have
said there are no micro
transactions so you would think you're
gonna have a way to unlock all of that
in the game
hey welcome to the new sub
me thrower
[Music]
yeah rtx 4000 yep should be out by then
[Music]
hope the game runs well enough on
previous generate yeah i feel like it i
feel like it'll run okay on uh ps4 and
xbox one it's the switch that i'm
that i'm worried about
but we'll see we'll see
no kelpie robe i know right the kelpie
robe got removed for the onyx hippogriff
mount
[Music]
at least according to the what we saw in
the leak it did not have onyx tipigriff
and then kelpie robe was added
[Music]
classic don't think you'll unlock those
in-game without buying that edition
debbie wait so you think they would if
you don't buy
digital deluxe then you're completely
locked out of this stuff
i've kind of just thought that i assume
you'll be able to unlock it like late
game through in-game currency that kind
of thing
yeah kelpie robe exactly high iq warrior
it is in the collector's edition yep
basically confirm you'll be able to fly
more than one animal with the uh onyx
hyper grip um
what do you what do you mean we knew
you'd be able to fly hippogrips already
so onyx i bet it's just uh probably a
black hippogriff
would be my guess
and then thestral mount yeah that i mean
that confirms we'll be able to fly
thestrals as well
what about dragons though what about
dragons
mary definitely think if you don't buy
it you won't get it really you guys you
guys are all pretty much in agreement on
that i'm
i don't know i'd be kind of surprised at
that
but
then it's like what would your ten
dollars really be going toward
[Music]
dude what
i'll tell you the one that will make
people mad is thestrals
if you can oh like who cares about a
a hat or whatever
but if you can only get festivals by by
buying the early
digital version or the the deluxe
version
that would make a lot of people mad dude
[Music]
wonder if the floating one can be used
as the harry potter magic caster one
thing oh i don't know
we still have to learn more about that
dragons oh yeah dragons would be awesome
or broom yeah we know brooms are in as
well we know brooms are in
oh that reminds me mrs weasley i should
probably add that
uh add the up time
[Music]
i don't think we have that programmed in
right now because nothing popped up for
you but we have been live for two and a
half hours
almost right on the dot two and a half
hours
everyone knows they'll grind the game if
they make it so you can unlock it on
your own might defeat the purpose of the
deluxe edition at all
yeah
true true
[Music]
yeah they need to answer that maybe
they'll answer that pretty soon like i
feel like those are questions that they
should should be able to answer once
they announce all the collectors edition
stuff
[Music]
and i feel like after tomorrow i'm
hoping that chandler will be able to
talk a little bit more and answer
questions he's been answering a lot of
questions on twitter today
he's been getting a little more active
hopefully we see even more of that
tomorrow
[Music]
some mounts in inquisition that were
exclusive to buying logitech and other
promos oh my gosh
[Music]
oh what do you guys think about the
early access
i'm not a fan
like if the game is ready three days
early
release it to everybody on february 7th
[Music]
come on
trust me
if if the collector's edition was good
enough we would have bought it anyway
[Music]
i mean because now that's basically
that's that's the de facto release date
the release date is not february 10th
it's february 7.
that is when the game will first be
playable for the masses
hey and thinking to the sub mickey henry
that just came in
appreciate you stopping by i appreciate
you supporting the channel
really yeah i feel like the early access
like that's
that is a big one
[Music]
i'm just not a fan like i'm just not a
fan of that being a pre-order incentive
[Music]
oh
like a three and it's three days 72
hours early access
early access is for those who want to
spend more money yeah it feels like
early access to me i mean you guys
you're
exactly you're you're
we're doing it because we want this game
so bad but it's kind of like i feel like
it's i don't know a little sleazy's not
the right word i wouldn't go that far
but i feel like it's a little
oh what's a good word for it
a little devious
a little devious i don't hate it i just
don't love it
[Music]
single player game not like it's an all
like yeah yeah
like in the gra in the grand scheme of
things in hogwarts legacy like
three days
it's nothing
[Music]
it's nothing
i mean after we've waited
how many years for this game
i thought early access was just standard
for any game you pre-order these days
slither slytherin yes
yes i love that slytherin is a good word
for it
could be pre-day one patch
yeah we'll have to deal
any of those early bugs you guys know
we're gonna be dealing with those that's
for sure
classic the thing about being left out
10 years ago well for this game like i'm
covering this game so closely
obviously i need to be able to play it
asap
it's a world i'm super passionate about
i'm making so much content for it i need
to get it out there as well
so of course i'm going to be down for it
but honestly like with anything else
i've kind of i've really changed my
stance on that over the years like i
used to have to i wanted to have every
game day one because i wanted to be part
of that conversation
and then as i've gotten older what i've
learned is it's like
that conversation it's it's still gonna
be there you know you can go back in the
reddit posts
you can go back in the forums now you
may miss out like on real-time things
kind of like twitter if you're trying to
interact with people like that but
yeah i used to be one of those day one
people every time
but now as maybe honestly it could be
because
i have two kids now a family a job
youtube stuff that i just don't have
time to play as many games anymore when
they release but
yeah it's just not as big of a deal
anymore for me to play day one it used
to be though it used to be
now i caveat all that by saying hogwarts
legacy of course day zero
i want to be playing it with you guys
deluxe edition so nothing official but
deluxe edition is the
um
eighty dollars
us dollars is what what we've seen
which i think is very reasonable
it's the collector's edition one that
has us all in a bit of a panic because
apparently it is gonna be 300
and does not include the art book does
not include the
soundtrack either
selling your early access is kind of
whack yeah that's that's another good
word for kind of whack
think the deathly hallows might make an
appearance
cj we've gotten a couple of deathly
hallows references now i shouldn't say
references more like hints i guess
there's this skull in this trailer right
here where we can clearly see the
triangle and a circle we just can't make
out the wand
[Music]
um we also saw the deathly hallows
appear
in textual form in the autodesk session
so i think they will at least be alluded
to in the world i don't know if they're
going to be factors in the main story
but i think we will at least hear of
them
[Music]
oh my gosh dude
spoilers i am that's another reason i'm
i'm terrified of streaming this game
honestly
[Music]
will the deluxe edition be digital
exclusive or both physical and digital
[Music]
okay wait well the deluxe edition
[Music]
no no so right here this version that
you see here this is the deluxe
which they are they are definitely
releasing this as a
hard copy version
as well as a digital version
because everything in the deluxe is all
digital it's all digital
the only benefit you would get by going
with the hard copy in addition to
getting you know the game is you get the
different artwork so this this cover art
is different
for the deluxe edition
what time is the trailer so the
collector's edition info is going to be
going live at 9 00 a.m eastern time
that's 6 a.m pacific time in the morning
yeah the trailer already the trail
already happened trailer is live
cascadia coming in with the
dollar super chat cascadia thank you so
much for the support of the channel
back in the day pre-ordering could get
you exclusive missions and that upset
everyone so now they just give you
earlier access not great but better than
it used to be yeah
college tradition and like deluxe
editions it's always been kind of a
tough thing because you don't want to
isolate
like especially in multiplayer games you
don't want to give people something
that's so overpowered that
but then you also it has to be something
cool to make it worthwhile
that's why i've always preferred like if
i want to go collector's edition or some
sort of deluxe edition that's why i've
always been a fan of the physical items
which i am not
i am not really a huge collector i don't
buy a lot of collectors editions i
really kind of pick and choose because i
mean i think
that puts the pressure on them you know
that they need to i mean collect
tradition it should be special it should
be unique it should be really cool items
that you want to physically display or
that you want to physically my big one
is i always love when they have
something you can use an item that you
can actually put to use and my favorite
one i was talking about earlier is the
infamous two collectors edition i still
to this day have the little backpack i
carry it to work every day it's like
what i use for my work bag
that bag has held up incredibly well
and it looks cool it looks very cool
lucas thank you for subbing to the
channel but yeah that's a good point
cascadia it's it's it's a tough balance
for
devs to strike or not really the devs
they're not really the ones who said it
it's more the publisher publisher side
of things on the
pricing and all that but cascadia thank
you for your support of the channel
thank you for the super chat
[Music]
let's see specifically says pre-order
the digital deluxe edition to get the
thestral and stuff i mean
there's no way this hard copy right here
does not include
pre-order oops pre-order the digital
deluxe edition and receive and then all
those things
but then you go here
there's no way that does not include the
same stuff
that they just showed
no way
but i see what you mean
and they also um
chandler tweeted
what did he say about the
[Music]
let me see what mr wood
said
we talked about this earlier but i just
want to ring it back up here
so this one right here and then in a
reply
this is the key art for our deluxe
edition the regular key art you're used
to
even if you undertake
oh so he doesn't actually say
[Music]
will this be the official cover art for
the game on release no according to it's
only cover for the deluxe
[Music]
oh dude to be like he doesn't say box
art but he says key art but you gotta
think they wouldn't show the box if
there wasn't a physical version of that
right
right
i would think so
hey
poet
gotta head out
got it work in the morning yeah me too
me too
thank you for stopping by and hanging
out though have a good one
[Music]
show the collector's edition on twitter
um
they haven't showed anything official
yet
it is apparently leaked though it's on
reddit and everything we were just
talking about it and had it pulled up
here earlier
[Music]
how evil will we
be able to get in the game lava could
ever be available at some point vodka
alvarez confirmed lucas yeah
i think it will only be usable as a
finisher type spell
i actually just posted a video on this
if you go and check my
most recent video this one right here
how evil can you be in hogwarts legacy
lot of it's still relevant even after
the trailer today a lot of this video
here is still
still relevant and will answer
a lot of your questions there
yeah never seen special edition items
only exclusive to digital
[Music]
reversible dude i love that idea
skylines that would be sick if you could
reverse it
oh that's actually a great idea i'm
gonna be mad if they don't do that now
you get to choose your path right come
on let us choose our box art
oh that'd be so
cool professor drew how often will i
release the newsletter
good question i'm thinking like once a
week right now
i might scale it back to once a month
but yeah right now i'm kind of thinking
once a week while we still have
i feel like i have plenty to talk about
if any of you were wondering what
professor drew's talking about here i
just started a newsletter and the first
one
we actually talked about what i know
about the hogwarts legacy delay
and why it was delayed why it was pushed
back
so it'll just be like some additional
musings of mine that don't always fit
into videos
because a lot of times with youtube
videos you're you're really trying to
you're trying to hit just like the three
to five main points and then you're out
these are a little bit more um in-depth
conversations are not really more
in-depth just like another uh
like another facet another little nugget
of information that maybe didn't fit
nice and neat into a video
but yeah i'm hoping to try to do once a
week if not um maybe like a twice
every two weeks or something like that
[Music]
hey thank you jake yeah this uh so the
music if any of you want to check it out
this is some copyright free music
available on youtube
tavern and in
is what we have here
oh wait that's not the right link oh
yeah it was yeah it was yeah it was
just posting it in the wrong spot there
right there there you go
now you guys should see it in the chat
if you want to check out the music
ps5 still in stock at ps direct
wow yeah if you guys are looking for ps5
today is apparently the day
i'm actually gonna text my cousin right
now
right now because he's been looking for
one
[Music]
apparently ps5
are
available online at sony
direct
have been most of the afternoon
[Music]
hey sir radical welcome
guy ps5 at walmart nice yeah i know
walmart had a restock today as well
ryan as a new cover i think they'll
change the color from green to red for
crucio as red as a vada cadaver
imperio's blue
[Music]
want to be an evil hufflepuff also when
a bunch of house points or headmaster
has to begrudgingly tell me
i'm fantastic while also knowing i'm
evil
[Music]
uh yeah cascadia was correct on the
collector's edition info tomorrow
morning nine a.m eastern
[Music]
do a live stream debating harry potter
wait what is what does that mean
debating harry potter
[Music]
do you think sebastian is slytherin's
family
um
we know sebastian has a family curse
but is he related to slytherin
dude if he is that maybe he is a parcel
mouth and that would explain why he is
able to open
that one door with the snakes that we
saw
[Music]
that would explain that
[Music]
playing the trailer one more time here
gotta prove the herbology professor's
the true
hey if they wanted to make a big shock
the biggest shock of all would be if the
professor weasley thing turns out to be
true which is not the redhead by the way
if professor weasley turns out to be
true that one turning out to be the one
behind it all that would be the biggest
twist of all
or the redhead herbology professor i
agree
john my favorite hogwarts legacy content
creator thank you for making quality
content also working full-time in
pharmacy school now watch your vids in
between studying john dude thank you so
much
i really appreciate you saying that
and hope pharmacy school is going well
yeah glad i can provide you some
entertainment there between
[Music]
i thought the door was the slytherin
common room
oh no so that door right there that just
that one right there
oh
is it the slytherin common room
[Music]
i guess the way the trailer progressed
oh no i don't think that's the common
room look you get the spider webs over
here
i think the way the trailer progressed i
assumed it was something inside this
dungeon so the first door we come to
let's jump back here
oh gotta jump back even more
that's the first door we come to so we
could just pass looks like we can pass
through right that one
right through that one or perhaps we
have to uh
this little medallion up here maybe we
have to activate something with that to
get this
to open up for us
but then we get to this section here
where
he says he has to teach us crucio or
cast it on us
because this doorway is a little
different this one has
right there has crucio in front of it
and then you're gonna be able to see it
in the background right here this door
here so this is inside the dungeon
and then we have the other one there
toward the end with the snakes
[Music]
which it's like
this creepy
oh boy that's another that's a different
door right there
which i just noticed something else that
i didn't catch the other time
oh that little pedestal
thing over on the right side
right there
[Music]
when the yotner edition went live
when the opener edition went live they
pulled the money out and then put it
back
until pickup
oh like when you um
yeah like a hold on your credit card
[Music]
look at the hall
yeah i was with you until i could see it
until i saw those um
i mean it could be but i think with all
these spider webs right here
i think we're still in the same place
that we are the rest of the trailer
right there
hey professor drew thank you for
stopping by and hanging out
trailer for other companions
that'd be kind of interesting if they
did if they had a trailer for all the
companions leading up to the
official release
see things are wide open now guys
because
after tomorrow so tomorrow's collector's
edition info
at that point things really open up for
them to
for their marketing to really kind of
go in many different directions
there's so many different directions
they could go in at that point
in terms of the cadence how often they
want to release things right now they're
sticking pretty closely to that thursday
release schedule
and it's kind of like little tidbits of
information we just had the asmr video
last thursday so that was a pretty big
one
so i think they'll stick with that for a
while i think back to hogwarts day
september 1st also a thursday
to me that that one makes a lot of sense
to show off the sorting
on that day and how we're going to do
the sorting
which chandler has promised that they're
still going to be showing off that final
tab of the character creator which we
haven't seen yet
so there's still a lot left that they
can reveal i still just want to see
i they really don't have to show me a
lot i just want to see some gameplay i
want to see some actual
moment-to-moment gameplay of what it
looks like
to actually play this game
to actually cast the spells
that's what i want to see like that
right this right here i want to know
what it looks like when i'm i'm
controlling that like what buttons am i
pressing
that's what i want to know
that's my next big thing that i can't
wait to see
[Music]
yeah we definitely need the gameplay
definitely need the gameplay soon
all right you guys it's been a blast man
i'm gonna hop off here and get my videos
ready to go live i'm gonna have
at least one video going up tomorrow
maybe more
um we did a little breakdown earlier in
the stream i'm gonna be posting those as
separate videos
you're also this whole live stream if
you missed any of it if you want to go
back and see my initial reaction and all
the discussion that followed you can go
back and check that out as well
all that will stay up and available on
the channel
a couple things before we go do not
forget about the pre-order
if you're at all interested in the
collector's edition we do not have
confirmation on price we don't know
right now we're hearing that it's 300
which is i think that's way too high
i think it's way too high
uh also for those of you who are just
tuning in if you missed the early part
of the stream i had a special
announcement today too
this shirt that i'm wearing right now
[Music]
order of merlin you guys you can get
this
on my official
merch store so it's
retrorecontour.creatorhyphenspring.com
did not want to sell these until i had
them in hand and i wanted to check and
make sure that the quality was
high quality
so now that i have had them in hand
the shirts are very soft they're very
soft
and then you got the nice design right
here the colors pop really well though i
do worry about i'll tell you guys just
being completely honest the one thing i
do worry about is i wonder how well the
screen print like when you wash it i
think i would definitely wash it just
like on cold and maybe just hang dry it
because i i don't want this design to
fade i could see that maybe fading over
time the stickers are also
insane they're amazing
and to give you an idea on the sizing of
the stickers they're almost as tall as
like a
a regular soda can
[Music]
you're a wizard
pretty good size there
so we got phone cases we got a mug
coffee mug we got posters all with order
of merlin and this is just the first of
a number of
wizarding inspired
merchandise coming to the store there's
a there's a couple more designs that i
have uh
been working with an artist on as well i
can't wait for you guys to see the rest
of them but the merlin one i was super
pumped about
super pumped about
nightly nerd 350
350 would be really insane
the rumor i saw said 300.
we'll see what ends up being true
cat daddy thank you for the subscription
welcome
[Music]
all right guys so i'm gonna go ahead and
hit the uh in screen
and i'm also going to let the music play
for a little bit
and
a lot i mean lots more to talk about
there'll be lots more to talk about
tomorrow after we get the official
collector's edition announcement
um
yeah so
thank you guys so much for the support
tonight was amazing i was really sad
that i didn't get to
stream this live with you guys i was
really disappointed but you guys made it
awesome here tonight as well so thank
you all so much
i will talk to you again soon
and uh yeah man have a great night thank
you all for being here
[Music]
you